You are now the CTO of
a 10 store. And two as of two months ago, they,
uh, build hardware for deep learning. Um,
how do you build scalable and efficient, deep learning?
This is such a fascinating space.
So it's interesting. So, um, up until recently,
I thought there was two kinds of computers.
There are serial computers that run like C programs and then there's parallel
computers. So the way I think about it, as you know,
parallel computers have given parallelism,
like GPS are great because you have a million pixels and modern GPU is running a
program on every pixel. They call it a shader program, right? So,
or like finite element analysis, you've built something, you know,
you make this into little tiny chunks, you give each chunk to a computer.
So you're given all these trunks of parallels like that.
But most of the programs,
you write this linear narrative and you have to make a go fast to make a go
fast. You predict all the branches, all the data fetches,
and you run that more parallel, but that's found parallelism. Um,
AI is,
I'm still trying to decide how fundamental it is is it's a given parallel is in
problem,
but the way people described the neural networks and then how they write
them and pie torch, it makes graph.
Yeah. That might be fundamentally different than the GPU kind of.
Parallelism yet. It might be because the,
when you run the GPU program on all the pixels you're running, but you know,
it depends, you know, this group of pixels say it's background blue.
And that runs a really simple program. Just pixel is, you know,
some patch of your face.
So you have some really interesting shader program to give you the impression of
translucency, but the pixels themselves don't talk to each other.
There's no graph, right?
So you do the image and then you do the next image, the next image,
and you run 8 million pixels, 8 million programs every time.
And modern GPU's have like 6,000 thread engines in them.
So they got 8 million pixels.
Each one runs a program on 10 or 20 pixels. And that's how,
that's how they work, but there's no graph.
But you think graph might be a totally new way to think about
hardware.
So Roger could Dora and I have been having this conversation about giving versus
fountain parallelism, and then the kind of walk as we got more transistors,
like computers, way back,
when did stuff on scalar data than we did on vector data,
famous vector machines. Now we're making computers that operate on matrices,
right? And then the, the CA the category we, we said that was next with spatial.
Like, imagine you have so much data that, you know,
you want to do the compute on this data. And then when it's done, it says,
send the result of this pile of data, run some software on that.
And it's better to think about it spatially then to
move all the data to a central processor, do all the work. So.
Especially, I mean, moving in the space of data as opposed to move in the data.
Yeah.
Yeah. You have a, give a petabyte data space,
spread across some huge array of computers.
And when you do a computation somewhere,
you send the result of that computation, or maybe a pointer to the next program,
to some other piece of data and do it. But I think a better word might be graph.
And all the AI neural networks are graphs.
Do some computations on the result here, do another computation,
do a data transformation, do emerging, do a pooling to another computation.
Is it possible to compress and say how we make this thing efficient,
this whole process efficient there's different.
First, uh, the fundamental elements in the graphs are things like metrics,
multiplies, convolutions data manipulations and data movements. Yeah.
So GPS emulate those things with their little singles, you know,
basically running a single-threaded program. Yeah. And then there's a, you know,
an Nvidia calls at,
or where they grew up a bunch of programs that are similar together.
So for efficiency and instruction use, and then the higher level, you kind of,
you take this graph and you say it as part of the graph is a matrix multiplier
was runs on these three 30 views reds.
But the model at the bottom was built for running
programs on pixels, not executing graphs.
It's emulation, ultimately.
So is it possible to build something that natively runs great?
Yes. So, so it tends torrented. So yeah.
Where are we on that? How, like, in the history of that effort,
are we in the early days? Yeah.
I think so 10 store it's started by a friend of mine LaBeija by Jack and I,
I was his first investor.
So I've been kind of following him and talking to him about it for years.
And in the fall when I was considering things to do, I decided,
you know, the, the, uh, we, we,
we held a conference last year with a friend organized it and, and we,
we wanted to bring in thinkers and two of the people were Andre capacity and
Chris Lattner and Andre gave this talk it's on YouTube called software
2.0, which I think is great,
which is where we went from programs, computers,
where you write programs to data program computers, you know,
like the futures of software as data programs, the networks.
And I think that's true. And then, um, Chris has been work.
He worked on LLVM the low level virtual machine,
which became the intermediate representation for all compilers.
And now he's working on another project called MLR,
which is mid-level intermediate representation,
which is essentially under the graph about how do you
represent a kind of computation and then coordinate large numbers of potentially
heterogeneous computers. And I would say,
technically tends torrents, you know, two pillars of those,
those, those two ideas software 2.0 and mid-level representation,
but it's in service of executing graft programs.
The hardware is designed to do that. So that's including the hardware piece.
And then the other cool thing is for a relatively small amount of money,
they did a test chip and two production chips.
So it's like a super effective team. And,
and unlike some AI startups where if you don't build the hardware to run the
software that they really want to do,
then you have to fix it by writing lots more software.
So the hardware naturally does matrix multiply, convolution,
the data manipulations and the data movement between processing
elements that, that you can see in the graph,
which I think is all pretty clever. And that's,
that's what I'm working on now.